my whole life since I was a kid I've
been working and it wouldn't be like
super famous
but I do know that if I'm here I have to
use that for good Selena Gomez breaks
down in tears in the new trailer for her
upcoming documentary my mind and me I
think that for me I'm really big on
vulnerability and that vulnerability
shows as the dock which drops November
4th on Apple TV plus follows the
actresses struggles with mental health
Selena Gomez was diagnosed with lupus
depression and anxiety
let me make a promise
I am going to stop living like this I
just want the free show how do I learn
how to Breeze my own Breath Again Sal's
latest project spans over six years
documenting her journey to present day
the triple threat makes this candid
confession while discussing her life in
the spotlight my whole life since I was
a kid I've been working and it wouldn't
be like super famous but I do know that
if I'm here I have to use that for good
what's holding you back from doing it
that I'm not good enough that's
something that I felt a lot of growing
up over the years Selena's been open
with fans about her struggles with her
mental health I'm very honest though in
general in 2018 she sought treatment for
it and in 2020 revealed during an
Instagram live with Miley Cyrus she was
diagnosed with bipolar disorder I
discussed that after years of going
through a lot of different things I
realized that I was bipolar when I
finally said what I was going to say I I
wanted to know everything about it and
it took the fear away I'm constantly
somebody that likes to grow and feel
like all right what could I be better at
what could I do better at where where
could my confidence be stronger what
makes me happy is connection and it
helps me get out of my head do you know
who this is yes she's real mommy went to
school with her clearly I'm still here
to use whatever I have to help someone
else everything that I had gone through
it's gonna be there I'm just making it
my friend now I am happier and I'm in
control of my emotions and thoughts more
than I have ever been and the trailer's
release date has a special significance
in the caption Selena writes every
breath a breakthrough in honor of
hashtag World mental health day
no this is the beginning for me I think
people are really scared to to be honest
with themselves and
strength is looked upon as oh I'm strong
I don't need anything I can't I can
handle everything and that's just not
the truth I want people to know that
every every single life is valuable that
their voice can be heard
foreign
[Music]